نحن موجودون الان قباله حي الشجاعيه في
الضواحي الشرقيه لمدينه غزه وواضح تماما
حجم الدمار الكبير الذي خلفته الاله
العسكريه الاسرائيليه في الايام وفي
الاسابيع الماضيه من خلال القصف المدفع
الشديد والغارات الجويه العنيفه التي
تركزت على حي الشجاعيه وعلى مختلف المناطق
الشرقيه لقطاع غزه واضح بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي ينتهج سياسه ممنهجه في اطار
عمليته العسكريه في تدمير الاف الشقق
السكنيه في تدمير الاف المنازل الفلسطينيه
في تلك المناطق واحالتها الى كومه من
الحطام بكومه من الحديد والاسمنت لمنع
الفلسطينيين من العوده اليها وتهجير
سكانها في اطار سعي الجيش الاسرائيلي
والمؤسسه الامنيه الاسرائيليه لاقامه
منطقه عازله في المناطق الشرقيه لقطاع غزه
وتحديدا في المناطق القريبه من السياج
الامني او تلك المناطق القريبه من البلدات
الاسرائيليه في غلاف غزه نستطيع ان نرى
حجم الدمار
الهائل دمار كبير خلفته الاله العسكريه
الاسرائيليه في كثير من الضواحي الشماليه
والشرقيه لقطاع غزه تحديدا هنا في حي
الشجاعيه وغيرها من الاحياء الفلسطينيه في
اطار اقامه هذه المنطقه العازله ومنع
الفلسطينيين من العوده الى
وربما توفير منطقه امنه كما يقول الجيش
الاسرائيلي للبلدات الاسرائيليه في منطقه
غلاف غزه وتمكين الاسرائيليين من العوده
الى بلداتهم هنا ليسك رام الجزيره من
قباله حي
الشجاعيه شرق مدينه غزه